today's successful companies can store
evaluate
and secure massive amounts of data
anyone with the data skills to design
and build data infrastructure is in high
demand
that is why employers are competing to
hire data architects to be the
visionaries that lead companies to
success with data
in udacity's data architect nanodegree
program
you can turn business requirements into
the blueprints for enterprise data
management systems
you will learn how to take the data
skills you already have to the next
level by building big data warehouse
solutions in snowflake
and designing data lake architecture
that supports big data processing
your customers trust is key you will
learn best practices in ensuring their
data is safe
and establish the processes to ensure
the quality
and integrity of all data throughout the
company
the projects you will build reflect the
business needs of today
you will design an end-to-end data
architecture framework that will ingest
big data
and transform it to a warehouse system
ready for analysis
data architects can be a
transformational force within
any company sign up for udacity's data
architect nanodegree program
today